[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up broth good day walter
good day
how are you
i'm hanging in there
but
you
better be hanging strong because we
still got a way to go i think the lord
will have to help us yes
speaking of that it's open with prayer
how open
our heavenly father we want to thank you
for bringing us together again lord we
want to discuss important things and we
want we cannot do it without your
enlightenment so we ask that the holy
spirit help us with this
and we ask that the viewers and all of
our discussions be blessed in jesus name
amen amen
so last time we were
finishing up and then we discussed some
a little bit of human enhancements yes
and
we got some information together we
didn't
plan
to go towards this i the lord helps us
putting things together
and today you can discuss
we're going to discuss something very
um
controversial controversial and we've
you know our many questions on this
topic we've had in the past unlimited
questions
and people want us to
take a position
we've been trying very hard to avoid it
yes
so the issue of vaccines and the mark
are they somehow connected and all of
these things
so i guess
it's time that we actually talk about it
and
uh we will make some friends and
some may not be so friendly afterwards
anymore
but that's the that's a decision that's
the way it goes yes
um i will start off i think with a video
yes about
it's a clip out of a cartoon series that
was
aired on netflix i think yes and um
just interesting
what they portrayed in there was two
seasons of this cartoon series and it's
always interesting to watch what they
hide or show in yes six cartoons you see
people always think that the mark is
something that will be
in your hand or in your forehead
and
that gives
total control
and so
you have you have this the sigilian
dialectic where some claim it is a very
positive thing and some claim it is a
very negative thing and in this little
movie they showed it to be super
positive turned out super negative and
had to be
sort of overcome by the hero it's like a
it's like a cue a non-victory
over evil in the end
and
we'll we'll just open with that
just to show that you know these issues
are out there
and even little minds are being
programmed but i wonder whether these
are for the little minds or whether they
are for the adult minds that are peeping
over the shoulder let's let's have a
look at it and see where we go
charter city is stunned by the sudden
rollout of rook unlimited's most
fantastic device ever
the smart mark throw your other devices
away because the smart mark is more than
just a phone it's part of you
use it as cash
book your travel
and even shoot video
distribution points are all over the
city and don't let the lines discourage
you the rook unlimited smart mark is
worth the wait
i never realized how wonderful
technology could make me feel the smart
mark has brought order to my life and
the best part it's absolutely free a
gift of thanks to our city from rook
unlimited
[Applause]
[Music]
23 of the population has been given the
smart mark number one time to test our
system number six
growing up in this city the streets of
old town i saw the worst mankind had to
offer chaos disorder
i vowed to make it all change
to make it all better
all these years working in secret
rising up the ranks of the tech men it
was all leading to this day order has
finally been established in charter city
no child will have to fear for their
safety again
the people owe you the greatest of debts
number one for liberating them from the
chaos of their lives
you guys love new tech you didn't want
to get smart marked
no way that's clearly some shady biz who
wants to be you call yourself a man of
science world order is our destiny
submit to a smart mark and join the
glorious victory of order over chaos or
you will be eliminated
grandpa mr savage uh where is everybody
ah they all went to get those foolish
new devices what no they can't grandpa
those things are dangerous it's a
conspiracy mind control ha i knew it
three hours is enough time for us to get
to our families maybe we can stop them
before they get marked
they seem to be establishing checkpoints
of some kind
this is how they keep order this is the
nightmare i warned you about people
think smart marks are brand new rook
tech that will improve their lives
they don't know they're being tricked
all smart marks so far but your chip
makes it possible to control everyone in
charge of city whether they're marked or
not
[Music]
that was quite interesting
they've got
something for
everything in the the mark the chip
and
that raised like five g yeah it looks
like 5g and control and all of those
issues and if you look there are many
subliminals as well
chess boards and all of these which
sort of give a masonic flavor to all of
this
so this is preparing humanity
for something
but on the other hand
ridiculing it at the same time this is
typical hegelian dialectic
now we've discussed the mark many many
times on this program
and the mark of the beast
is the mark of
the beast system and the beast is
defined
in the bible
by all the points that are given in
revelation chapter 13 correlated with
daniel chapter 7
and all the reformers were
of one accord that that was a reference
to the papal system
and
when the reformation
started
gaining momentum one of the orders that
was created to
subvert it and to conquer it eventually
was the jesuit order
and the jesuit order introduced a
totally new philosophy also a new
biblical philosophy
in terms of the antichrist because it
didn't suit their gender at all that the
papacy was
marked as antichrist right
and so the jesuit order was created in
order to destroy protestantism and
protestant principles
and bring the world back to papal
dominance
so the biblical criteria and the
biblical prophetic interpretation had to
be removed
and replaced by another one that suited
them and so the jesuits brought about
the whole issue of dispensationalism
the future antichrist that would come
now why would the bible even concern
itself with a future antichrist where no
christian is involved because he's
raptured those are all jesuit
theological ideas
that were introduced to counter the
reformation
and today there is a spiritual war
and we really have to talk about the
spiritual war now the spiritual war
unfortunately also is associated with a
physical
war
they have to control
the way in which you operate the way in
which you think
now if an image to the beast is to be
created then a system must be put in
place that will emulate what the beast
did yeah
and the beast the roman catholic system
operated by controlling humanity through
its dictates
and dogmas
and religious systems
so there must be a similar system set in
place the state was used to enforce
the
dogmas of romanism
and the military and the police were
employed in order to make sure that
everything
maintains the status quo and the order
that was set up
so an image must emulate that system so
we must somehow get it all together
and because the final issue really is
worship
there will be a contrast between the
mark of the beast
and the mark of god yes
now if you go into a bible study and
we've done it before so we're not going
to go into that we're just going to look
at the issue the mark of god
was clearly the sabbath
why because it's the sign of his
authority yes
it's the sign of his creative power
it is the sign of he being your creator
and that you should worship him who made
the heaven the earth the sea
and all that is in them
and in contrast there is another mark of
authority and the papacy
changed the sabbath to the sunday
so
it's an issue of a day but the day is
coupled to authority who has authority
yes
who do you accept as your god in your
life exactly and the jesuits were not
only instrumental in
tremendous
upheavals in society revolutions wars
the inquisition
they were
the champions of paper of of papal rome
and their cruelty
in history is well recorded and you just
have to go to the congressional records
to see
what their oath of allegiance is all
about you just have to
listen to what the presidents of the
united states and world leaders over the
ages have said what protestant writers
have written
to understand exactly what they are all
about i mean the gunpowder plot trying
to destroy the bible getting rid of
god's word by any means possible yes
that's in the in their creed that's what
their job is right
so now
when when you see the the way in which
history is being played out on the world
stage today
we have to look at these issues and keep
them carefully separated
now one of the issues was the mark
and there are many people that claimed
when you
receive a vaccination
automatically they will introduce
a chip and they mark
and they said well that is the mark of
the beast
but the mark of the beast is about
worship yes
so it it is about who do you acknowledge
as the authority in your life
and the vaccination process that is you
know in vogue today in the world
is just one of the means whereby
eventually you will get a system of
control
yes
would you agree with that yes
because the bible says that the mark of
the beast will be enforced
that you won't be able to buy that you
won't be able to sell
that you won't be able to be active
economically and thereby being
deprived of the substance of life you
will capitulate that's coercion
and whatever means people use to coerce
someone to do something that is against
their will
is not from god correct
so we have to look into this issue so
that just has a background so we have to
look at the role players which we've
done to some extent
and then we'll have to look at the the
whole issue of vaccine which seems to be
the vehicle
yes it's just a vehicle that's it
whereby
something will be introduced which will
totally change humanity's perception and
may be used for control
absolutely so we have to look at the the
ethics behind the vehicle
now
uh i was active in the medical world
myself i was professor of medical
bioscience
so i'm not a molecular biologist but in
terms of
the genetic system i mean i did lecture
on genetics even to postgraduates
so
the complexity of the issue is perhaps
not something that everybody is
acquainted with
and we will try and just put it in
simple terms and then there's as i say
an ethical and ethical aspect that we
have to look at
i will praise thee for i am fearfully
and wonderfully made
marvelous are thy works and that my soul
knoweth right well
now i come from the scientific
fraternity
and they don't believe in creation
in fact they say
that science cannot allow a divine foot
in the door
god must be totally separated from
science
if you believe in creation then you will
believe that whatever god created was
good
how good
very good aha does he say that yes yes
we go through the days of creation
and we are told that everything that god
made was
good
very good
now when you
when you
subvert
that understanding and you introduce
the theory of evolution into
humanity's thinking
then of course
how do you know that it's very good if
you developed out of the slime perhaps
it could be improved right correct so if
you come with an evolutionary mindset
then everything in is in progression in
the process of becoming
better of becoming better right
and the fact that we are so good at the
moment i mean it works we're alive we
can do things we can talk we can
communicate we can see we can hear i
mean it's just mind-boggling
what the human being or the creatures in
this world can do
now imagine if you can enhance that
that's where a.i comes in right yes
in the last one yes as we saw
they're already busy with the technology
absolutely so we're going to enhance the
human mind you remember they asked the
mask
tell me do you think we can put a whole
language in there well he was arming and
awing and going this way and that way
well god can what happened at pentecost
yes
well you can actually
even
take it further what happened at
babel with nimrod exactly
they all had different languages yeah
and then you put it back together in at
pentecost that correct and
this it actually says the idia dialect
in your own mother tongue in other words
you can speak it as though you were a
native of the language right
so
god designed that mind in the beginning
to be able to
accommodate
many many things that because of sin
have been deactivated we will go into
that discussion
later
but the fact of the matter is we are
fearfully and wonderfully made
and perfect yes good
very good
now
if you have this philosophy
would you mess with something that is
very good
or would you only by messing with it
make it deteriorate i think that's the
part that happens okay so depending on
what your starting philosophy is
it will determine
your modus operandi and your thinking
now that's important when it comes to
vaccines and things we'll be talking
about that in a moment
so if you start with the assumption that
god created
or you start with the assumption that
you evolved out of the slime that makes
a difference yes now where do the
jesuits stand
on the evolution side absolutely yes the
big bang theory is an
evolutionary theory that derived from
the jesuits directly
if you take
their great thinkers tyler de sadeen
and all of these who was probably by you
know by all the evidence even
involved in the great hoax of changing
uh the skulls so that they would depict
evolution and all of those things so
they they have the evolutionary line you
know everything must improve and they
basically
further the theology
that the human being is a god
so you have in the new age thinking you
have the divinity of man
in catholicism
we've dealt with it so we're not going
to deal with just giving a dust
background you have this philosophy that
humanity is basically god
and therefore you can play god
and if you can play god and if you
evolved out of the slime pit and on the
way
to improvement
then maybe you can interfere in the
process and improve it some all right
yeah
as
um
morgan freeman said in that one
clip that we saw
of
god that he made a documentary on yes he
said the god in me is the best me
that i can be
like something in that no it's a you
know i'm looking at uh many of these
channels where you have this conspiracy
channels so called
those people are all new agers all of
them they all believe that they are that
they're basically divine definitely and
that we are on this road to absolute
perfection it's a scary thought it is
scary most of these people that are
exposing all these
bad things and conspiracy theories and
so on are themselves new ages absolutely
i never even realized this in the
beginning when i started looking at them
because some of the things they're
saying are very logical
but when it comes down to the philosophy
they seem to be religious well some seem
to be totally a religious but many of
them seem to be religious
and they are on
the biblical bandwagon
but with a totally
twisted messed up twisted
idea
god
is the one who created this world
and god is the one who gave us freedom
of choice and god created us perfect
and we are fearfully and wonderfully
made
jesuit philosophy
is the opposite of that jesuit
philosophy is the enemy
of god in all its forms
so
let us just talk a little bit about
vaccines
we'll talk about
not only what they are
what they can possibly do
and who are the people involved
behind it because that's very important
and the industries
behind it
now
when you think about vaccines
and are they possibly the vehicle
whereby this control will be introduced
like we saw
you know mark of the beast and all of
those things
the vaccines in themselves
how were vaccines created in the past
well there was a particular vector
that was causing disease whatever it is
if it was smallpox or if it was polio or
whatever it was
and
in those cases you would take the vector
and you would take a weakened form of it
either by injecting the dead vector
or a heat
damaged vector so that it wouldn't
effectively give you the disease
but that there was enough of it there
for your body to create an immune
response
and then your body would create
antibodies against this antigen that was
introduced into your body
and then your cells
would remove it
take it through the liver or through the
kidneys depending on the species and
eliminate the danger out of your body
that's how it used to work
now
that is something that is
scientific your body would react to any
foreign
body that comes into you
in the same way
and create this response and that is
something that worked it certainly
helped with smallpox and polio and all
of these issues
then later they started perfecting it
and they started adding
things to
the vaccines
and
nanoparticles of aluminium were added
and many many other components and
multiple vaccines were created
and you know the is the human body
designed to cope with
a whole plethora of diseases at the same
time
all of these issues then become
important because it later became an
issue not only
of
human health
it became an industry yes
and that's important
and it became a very lucrative industry
and fear is a great driving force in a
lucrative industry like this
and over the years people have
expressed some of these fears and made
some correlations
and the mainstream has rejected that and
many of the videos that were made
on this issue were just summarily
discarded some of them were removed
i mean you know about that
and the question is is there anything of
substance
in what these people are saying
now there was a video made
where
they talked about the effect of vaccines
on autism and other issues and this was
very
rapidly removed let's just look at some
of the issues that were raised there
we're not taking a stand we're just
giving information at this stage
[Music]
so you make the documentary the position
has been given the data shows us in 1975
one in every 5 000 kid
has autism
1982 one in 2500 1994 one in 500 2 000 1
and 166 2004 1 and 150 2009 1 and 110
2011 168 2013 1 and 45 projected 2032
one out of every two kid is gonna have
all right that's catastrophic right
you put the documentary out there
tribeca turns it down
robert de niro who is somebody
politically would have typically
disagreed with someone like you but
because at the time his 16 year old son
has autism he's around 21 22 today he's
emotionally connected to it and he's
trying to hold himself back he says i
believe everybody should watch this
right okay
yeah everybody starts looking at this
emails you've gotten from both sides
people that have connected with you from
both sides what's been the best argument
you've gotten
from those who say dell you're a fool
you're absolutely wrong you're not even
looking at it from this standpoint why
are you still doing this arguing about
vaccine this is a hoax this is a
propaganda you're hurting so many kids
lives you're doing this i work on the
doctor's television show so i started
asking every doctor i knew including
hosts on the doctors and i said if i'm
wrong
show me where i'm wrong i want off this
road i mean i'm all about the truth
please show me explain to me what i'm
missing here how is this data wrong how
is it show me a study that can disprove
what we're seeing here and i'll be
honest no one has ever actually done
that they cannot say that they're safe
period
full stop end of story i'm not
anti-vaccine i'm anti-injecting number
one products that don't do for safety
studies and number two products that
have liability protection meaning i
cannot sue the manufacturer if it does
injure me or does injure my children and
the reason that's problematic is i know
since they've never been able to be sued
since the 1986 act that took all
liability away there's been no market
incentive to evolve the science of
vaccines they have absolutely zero risk
so you know money people why would
anybody spend money for no reason to
evolve a product and make it safer than
it already is if you can't sue them
anyway vaccine cover 19 with them
telling us the fact that you know it's
the most important vaccine we got to
take if it comes out now obviously at
this point of the game you don't seem
very confident about any of the vaccines
yourself but if they come out with this
vaccine and they're presenting it to us
that we ought to take it whether it's
voucher or gates how confident are you
and us needing to take this cover 19
vaccine
so
the issue of autism
i mean that has been trashed by the
mainstream media and they say that there
is no correlation
but if you look at that increase
over time
it is phenomenal
and the links
that people have are also phenomenal
they're saying it's not that it's
something else well what is the
something else then
now these are very serious issues
the issue of a vaccine
therefore has implications
not necessarily the vaccine itself but
the additives
and the modern generation of vaccines is
a totally different issue again we'll
look at that as well
now if people have fears about
these things like the increase in autism
and what it does to your child
should they have the right to refuse
a vaccine
well
it's interesting that dot news in
australia tells us that victorian police
can now enter homes without a warrant
as part of a new four-stage lockdown
restrictions announced this week
victoria premier dan andrews has cited
harsher penalties for those found not
following
covet 19 directions
so the police are involved
now what if the covert 19
directions start including enforced
vaccination yes would the police then
also be involved
definitely
the public health and wellbeing act of
2008 states that authorities can close
any premises
and without a warrant into any premises
and search for and sees anything that is
necessary for the purpose of
investigating eliminating or reducing
the risk of public health
so we do have a situation in the world
today
where public authority
can interfere in your personal choices
that's just the fact
now they're saying this is for the
common good right correct now where does
that idea come from again jesuits
and it's not only in just in australia
now in
new york
they've also
starting to implement
the same type of measures okay so let's
have a look at that just to see where
we're going
so today de blasio announced that he
plans to encircle the entire city with
military-style checkpoints not to stop
violent criminals but prevent people
from visiting from other places
there was no public discussion of this
ahead of time there was no debate de
blasio just decreed it
so starting today we're going to do
something new in new york city we will
have checkpoints at key entry points to
the city
travelers coming in from those states
will be given information about the
quarantine they will be reminded that it
is required not optional
they'll be reminded that failure to
quarantine is a violation of
state law and it comes with serious
penalties in fact under certain
circumstances the fines can be as high
as 10 000
so in a few days new york will begin
following and harassing travelers
they're going to text and call you if
you plan to travel if you don't respond
city workers may come to your home in
person
listen to a man called ted long explain
the plan he runs something called the
test and trace core in new york
tomorrow we're going to be deploying
teams to penn station to stop travelers
to ensure that they've completed the
travel form we've made more than 86 000
phone calls to travelers coming into new
york city from the designated high risk
states and we've sent more than 20 000
text messages to date and if we can't
get through to you on the phone we've
deployed teams that are now knocking on
your door to check in with you
so eventually when they get to
make vaccination compulsory and you need
a certificate to prove it
will they do the same kind of thing you
think i think so so
this is about control
now that in new york the quadrant is for
the quarantines on the on the covet 19.
but there's also now been a few
news outlets that's been
doing coverage
of
will it be legal for them to
force the vaccine on you okay let's look
at that
as we race to develop a coronavirus
vaccine some major questions are
emerging a lot of people are wondering
if the government could force people to
get it or could people who refuse get
banned from stores or lose their jobs
imagine a world where you have to get
vaccinated and show proof to go shopping
board a plane or just go to work
legally it could happen says university
of san diego law professor dov fox
states can compel vaccinations in more
or less intrusive ways they can limit
access to schools or services or jobs if
people won't don't get vaccinated it
could force them to pay a fine or even
lock them up in jail those measures have
been adopted in other countries like
france but not so far in the united
states courts have found that when
medical necessity requires that the
public health outweighs the individual
rights and liberties professor fox says
states would need to allow exemptions
for people with legitimate medical risks
like pregnancy but not exemptions for
other reasons
religious exemptions philosophical ones
have largely been overridden in the name
of public health and legal experts say
that private businesses would have the
authority to fire workers who don't want
to get vaccinated for personal or
religious reasons companies would just
need to show that there are significant
costs at stake for having unvaccinated
employees
that's interesting yes
serious that's a serious issue
so now
we are slowly moving from a purely
health issue into a moral issue as well
and we will have to determine how
morally
invasive
this is if at all and then also who do
who determines
if it's moral or not yes who is behind
because if they say it's moral
um then they have to do it for the
common good they could we've heard
today right yes and who are they
yeah this is this is becoming very very
interesting that um law professor i
think his law professor said
it outweighs
your personal freedom yes when it's in
for the common absolutely
now here's a roman catholic site called
life site
and it says trump is to mobilize the
military to deliver covet vaccine to
millions very very quickly
so trump said that the military general
is overseeing the logistics of
delivering the vaccine once it is
developed
we actually have a clip of him
saying these things perhaps we can go
there
of course
they are not contrary to the idea here
because amid growing concerns about the
safety and efficacy of the covet 19
vaccine president donald trump has
announced his administration is all set
to march
when it comes to the coronavirus vaccine
now there's something interesting here
that we need to talk about
on the one hand
you know you're always saying that he's
draining this the swamp right
now in that swamp according
to the media out there you have all
these pro-vaccine people yes
now outside of the swamp you have donald
trump
exactly he's supposed to drain the swamp
where
bill gates is forming part of it yes and
he's the guy that's behind those
vaccines and here he is pushing for
vaccines so he's playing both sides of
the field so right so
if if this covet
is really the culprit now we're not
taking sides we're just discussing the
issue
then
this forced vaccine becomes very
interesting so we have to look at this
very carefully yes so let's have a look
at the next one
one issue that has come up is once you
do have a vaccine how do you properly
distribute it
how do you get it out quickly when we
have the vaccine we have the military
all lined up and the military is going
to be doing it
uh in a very powerful manner
these are people that don't usually do
vaccines they do soldiers and they do
lots of other things that frankly are
more difficult but we have
our general and logistically he's all
set uh tony do you want to say something
about that that is correct um
as the vaccine rolls out we'll be
getting them distributed and as
you probably have heard we are going to
make sure that we do it in an equitable
way and it's representative of the
populations who need it the most
and we have the the standard way that we
determine that with the acip working
with the cdc but dr
uh collins and dr redfield have put
together with the national academy of
medicine uh a group that will fortify
that decision-making process so that
we're making sure that we're very fair
and equitable in getting the vaccine
distributed properly
and i think i could have francis say
that tremendous progress has been made
on the vaccine beyond anything that we
would have thought
if you go back six months uh what do you
think uh it is just frankly quite
astounding mr president i've been at a
night for 27 years and director for 11
and i've seen some amazing things happen
but the way in which the whole research
community public and private uh
philanthropies everybody has come
together to work on this not worrying
about who gets the credit
trying to figure out how to strip away
anything that's going to slow things
down
and i think all of us
motivated by the fact that this is the
most serious problem we've encountered
in our professional
lifetimes the most serious problem we
have encountered and
everything is being stripped away that
will hold this up it has to be
implemented
quickly yes
we'll have to talk about that as well in
terms of the science
and in terms of the ethics now again
dr fauci
was very prominent
and
we talked about his jesuit connections
in the past and
some people say well you know that's
just his training it does that's not his
philosophy he was just trained medically
but that's not the case
he's actually deeply involved in jesuit
thinking
and we know that church and state will
work together to achieve total control
and eventually to implement the true
mark of the beast
which is an issue of worship right
so we're now not only interested in the
process of enforcing it using the
military
but also in the people involved in the
process and this is important from a
from a prophetic biblical perspective
yes
so it's important that we just
make sure
is dr fauci just a
medical man who happened to be trained
by the jesuits or does the jesuit
thinking permeate his mind yes
maybe even more
than we think
let's see
the jesuits taught you high school
college holy cross right regis high
school in manhattan what what impact
what does it mean to be taught by
jesuits we hear about
jesuits all the time well it's
it's
it's a great experience i have to say
they combine
um intense intellectualism
with uh
discipline not in the sense of you know
smacking you around but intellectual
rigor discipline in how you handle
yourself as a person as a human being
and they have a a general motto of and i
think this had a major influence on me
and what i did
is the issue of service to others that's
very big that doesn't mean that people
who don't go into public service are
doing anything lesser with their lives
but they tend to have a um
i wouldn't say a pushing
but a leaning towards something about
what you do is public service either
everything you do which turned out what
i did by going into public service or at
least a part of your life so it was a it
was an interesting combination of
concern for mankind
as well as
a good intellectual rigor when did you
want to be a doctor can you remember the
time i think it was early high school i
i'm very interested in people i'm a very
much of a people person and
probably as part of the jesuit training
which is very steep in the classics and
the humanities so when i went to regis
high school we took four years of greek
four years of latin a romance language
and
ancient history and things like that
when i went to holy cross
which is another jesuit school as a
college
i took kind of a hybrid pre-med course
it was called it's almost an oxymoron it
was called a b
greek classics dash premed
so
you were majoring in the humanities and
the classics with a lot of philosophy
but you took enough science to get into
medical school and
the idea about when i wanted to become a
doctor i liked science i liked discovery
i liked the uh challenges of science but
i also so much liked
mankind than the humanities that it was
just a natural fit
that where do you put science and people
in the same bucket and to me that was
medicine who was an early mentor
probably some of the very young
uh jesuits in
um
regis high school
in the jesuit training it's a long long
training before you become a jesuit
priest
and back then they were had which called
scholastics were people who weren't yet
ordained as priests but they dressed
with the garb of a priest and they
taught in
in the high school and there were a
couple of those scholastics who had a
major impact on me just great people
highly intellectual and highly nurturing
of you and what you wanted to do
i mean he even made speeches for
different
jesuit colleges encouraging the students
so let's look at the next one and see
what he has to say there to the students
i had the good fortune to graduate from
regis high school in 1958
i often say it was the best educational
experience i could have imagined
i became immersed
in the intellectual rigor
of a jesuit education
importantly
certain tenets of the jesuit tradition
have sustained me
throughout my life and career
two of these
precision of thought and economy of
expression
inform how i think
how i write
and how i communicate with the public
every day
especially during the present unsettling
times
just as important however
is the jesuit emphasis on social justice
and service to others
and now is the time if ever there was
one
for us to care selflessly about one
another
and so congratulations on your
graduation
stay safe
and be well as you celebrate this
important milestone of your life
i wish you all the best
in the years ahead
so dr farsi
seems to be steeped in jesuit thinking
jesuit philosophy
jesuit thinking on social justice which
is the roman catholic system of control
and
we must never forget
that these formidable foes of the gospel
will do anything under the garb of
christianity including
showing a great concern
for mankind in order to further the ends
of the papacy yes
and this is a very important issue
and
i have a serious serious problem
when it comes to this philosophy because
it has been designated over the
centuries
as the enemy of the gospel
national geographic talking about covet
19 vaccines could become mandatory
and here's how it might work
after a covet 19 vaccine is available
you may need to get inoculated to go to
the office
attend a sporting event or even get a
seat at a restaurant
in other words
the issue of buying and selling and
being economically active
will become very serious
now as we said if this is a vehicle yes
for a later thing to come the final
issue
attacking the authority of god
then we need to know about it
so there's a lot of talk of it becoming
mandatory right
that's correct
this is the future as some experts see
it a world in which you'll need to show
you've been inoculated against the novel
coronavirus to attend a sports game get
a manicure go to work go to work right
or hop on a train
you'll be totally restricted without it
adult vaccine mandates compelling
employees and the public to inoculate
themselves aren't nearly as widespread
but they're not unheard of u.s states
and cities can and have forced
compulsory vaccinations on citizens
in 1901 for example cambridge
massachusetts adopted a law that
required all citizens age 21 and older
to get vaccinated against smallpox
failure to comply could lead to a five
dollar fine or the equivalent of a
hundred and fifty dollars today
now they were speaking about ten
thousand dollars right so that's quite a
hike those who challenged the order in
court
lost
so you have no recourse
while the enforcement of such mandates
wouldn't be without its challenges it
would hardly be impossible or without
president
well if you're going to get the military
involved and those are
hardened soldiers yes what would you
expect trump was saying that they are
used to handling
exactly so
how much easier for them to handle
the man on the street
to board an emirates flight to dubai
today for example all passengers must
present a negative covert 19 test
certificate
once a vaccine is available airlines
could put in place sweeping regulations
required covet 19 vaccination
certificates so this is all still
speculation
but everything is geared towards it i
mean we were speaking in the previous
episodes about the qr code
everything is now vex
covered 90 negative related yes but
eventually it can go over to vaccine
regular regulated so you don't have it
you can't enter the shop
correct
here's an article from rt and it says
bubble indemnity big pharma firms will
not be held accountable for side effects
of covet vaccine that's unheard of yes i
don't think that was a situation when
they were working on the smallpox
vaccine in those in 1901 absolutely you
had recourse to courts if something
happened now these people are free they
can do whatever they want
so this is something that can be
exploited by big farmer to make big
bucks
and you can't be sued yeah if something
goes wrong so i really want to know
what's going on with these vaccines if
that is the case are you then worried of
what you what the consequences can be of
what you put in the vaccine or are you
going to rely on human kindness so that
it will be perfect
i mean the jesuits and their reason
and the depopulation agenda as we see it
on the georgia guide stones
uh i don't know whether i trust humanity
to the point of well inject whatever you
like right
so a senior executive for the
pharmaceutical giant astrazeneca has
confirmed that his company cannot face
legal action for any potential side
effects caused by its covert vaccine
those affected will have no legal
recourse that is horrendous
we can say that blatantly
in this discussion right
now this next video is a public health
committee and it's a public hearing and
we have medical doctors giving their
opinions experts in the field
you know because there are so many
people
that say just run with what the
mainstream is telling you
well this is mainstream
and it is an opinion that doesn't sit
very well with the general
thought on this issue
because we have so many people
that
say that these anti-vaccine people are
you know just against public order and
against science and against this and
against that so let's talk about the
science
and let the scientists talk about the
so let's hear what this man has to say
because i think this was a very
important one that everybody should be
aware of
some of the vaccines and the ingredients
in the vaccines we've heard about could
be aluminum could be mercury is there
some concern that when these
ingredients are given to such young
children that that as we've heard their
immune systems are not completely
developed yet if it stays in their
system and or stays in their brain and
does not come out of their system as
what we've heard is
supposedly supposed to leave their
system what are your thoughts on that um
well you heard earlier that there's no
real concern about aluminum because it's
such a small amount and so it really
shouldn't matter but the kind of
aluminum that we put into vaccines is a
different kind of aluminum that we see
environmentally this is called a
nanoparticle and nanoparticles
bind really tightly to the bacteria
antigens the virus antigens the food
protein antigens and any other
contaminants that are in the vaccines
that we may not know about and we know
that the biochemical properties of
nanoparticles is that they are capable
of entering the brain
and so we have not
evaluated the safety of the aluminum
nanoparticle and its injection and where
it goes when it gets into the body and
whether it gets into the brain
do vaccine ingredients belong in the
brain no
do they get into the brain no one has
ever studied it but animal studies using
the same chemicals that are in vaccines
that we give to children
directly demonstrate that the vaccine
ingredients do enter the brain
we are ignoring this information there
are scientists in europe who've actually
done studies on the aluminum
nanoparticle and have shown that it can
persist in the brain for years and
decades
and so what we're seeing is a large
outbreak of neurodevelopmental
disabilities in adults
including alzheimer's
and one of the main factors that they're
finding in the brains of people with
alzheimer's is the aluminum nanoparticle
that's directly related to the vaccines
that we're giving
so we have never studied
whether the aluminum that we're giving
in vaccines
gets into the brain and we've never
measured whether it stays in the brain
and what it does if it does stay in the
brain
but we do know that vaccines are
supposed to cause inflammation in the
body
but we have more than half of our
children with chronic inflamed
conditions
and we've never allowed ourselves to ask
the question
if the vaccines cause inflammation
acutely
do they continue to create
inflammation chronically we have one in
five with neurodevelopmental
disabilities one in ten with add and
adhd one in 35 with autism one in 11
with asthma
and one in 20 under the age of 5
with seizures and the autoimmune
diseases are exponentially rising and we
are finding that the viruses and the
bacteria that we're injecting into the
body
along with the adjuvants
create something called molecular
mimicry
which means the body sees those viruses
thinking that it's foreign but actually
finds
pieces of those viruses that match
pieces of the self and the immune system
doesn't differentiate between what it's
been told to reject and itself so it
will
turn the immune system on itself leading
to an autoimmune condition we know this
about hepatitis b we know it about the
gardasil vaccine and we know it about
the flu vaccine and we continue to say
unequivocally that the vaccines have
been studied effectively and that
they're safe and that's just not true
that is a very interesting
testimony yes
very interesting indeed
so these nanoparticles the aluminum and
those things that they put in them
cross
the blood-brain barrier
and they accumulate in the brain now in
the past when i was still at the
university this was a big issue
is the accumulation in the brain a
result
of the alzheimer's or is it a causative
factor in the alzheimer's
was it a prion disease or
something else that caused that debate
has been raging for many years now
the fact of the matter is that
autoimmune diseases
are
increasing exponentially
he also reiterated the autism
figure
which used to be one in 5 000 and is now
1 in 35
i mean that is absolutely horrendous
what has changed has humanity changed in
the last
few decades to such an extent that we've
deteriorated to the point that very soon
one in two children will have autism
i don't know whether people realize
what
autism actually does
and
what the effect can be it it is
horrendous
and
the dissociation that can take place i
mean it comes in degrees
it can be very severe or it can be less
severe
but if you are fearfully and wonderfully
made
and you are designed to
operate in the environment in which you
live
and your immune system is
designed to cope with the rigors of life
are we playing god when we
add all of these things
now i as i said
i wouldn't be against vaccines if it was
a vector that is being injected in a
harmless state to induce a immune
response against the possible
more aggravating
vector
but when you add all of these things
and the science has been accumulating
that there is a problem
then
it is something really to consider but
it gets worse
here is a
article from the world health
organization
and there's the webpage
and we're talking now about dna vaccines
you see what this man previously spoke
about
was
the additional substances in the vaccine
now
when you inject
the vaccine the antigen
whatever the antigen is
the body
has an immune response so it makes an
antibody
the antibody binds to the antigen
and then eventually it is eliminated by
your lymphocyte cells taken to the liver
processed and the body gets rid of the
problem that's how your immune system
works and this all happens at the plasma
level
now
the modern vaccines that they are making
are
based on a totally different principle
so
we've taken this
web page here from the world health
organization just to show that this is
really what they are doing now
vaccination consists of stimulating the
immune system with an infectious agent
or component of an infectious agent
modified in such a manner that no harm
or disease is caused
but ensuring that when the host is
confronted with that infectious agent
the immune system can adequately
neutralize it before it causes any ill
effects
and that is how vaccines have worked in
in the past
and this is a logical approach
so
i'm not
anti-vaccine per se
when we come to the modern vaccines
we've we've dealt with the additives but
now look what what's going to happen
here so they say for over a hundred
years
vaccination has been affected by one of
two approaches either introducing
specific antigens
against which the immune system reacts
directly
or introducing live attenuated
infectious agents that replicate within
the host without causing disease
synthesize the antigens that
subsequently
prime the immune system so you're adding
this issue and the body responds
now
they're going to do it differently
recently a radically new approach to
vaccination has been developed and this
is where it gets interesting
it involves the direct introduction into
appropriate tissues of a plasmid
containing the dna sequence encoding the
antigen or genes
against which an immune response
is sought
and relies on the in-situ production of
the target antigen
so now you're introducing
dna
the building blocks of life
sometimes they introduce it in the form
of rna which is a single strand and not
a double helix
now
dna
and rna from a foreign source
will not enter your nucleus
the nucleus i'm going to use the word
design
is
magnificently designed the whole cell
is a a marvel
that will keep the scientific minds
occupied for a lifetime
and the nuclear membrane has ports
with gates
with keys and locks to put it simply
and substances must enter in and come
out
through
this nuclear pore
and certain large molecules like rna for
example that is produced when proteins
are to be made the dna will encode for
rna
the rna
will then be transported through the
nuclear membrane through these pores
through the gateway which will open up
to the exact formation of what has to
pass through so that only that passes
through and nothing else
because the composition of the nucleus
is different to the cytoplasm on the
outside
and this is such a precise
way
so nothing can actually enter that
nucleus that doesn't pass through the
gatekeeper right
so when they introduce dna or rna into
the cell and they want to get it into
your
replicating site into the nucleus they
have to use a nanoparticle
to carry it in otherwise the body would
destroy it it wouldn't get in so you're
fooling the body
you're fooling the cell
to take in a substance which is foreign
okay let's continue
this approach offers a number of
potential advantages over traditional
approaches including the stimulation of
both b and t cell responses
improved vaccine stability the absence
of any infectious agent so they're not
giving you
a reduced form of
smallpox for example
and the relative ease of large-scale
you're now producing
a dna sequence or an rna sequence
as proof of the principle of dna
vaccination immune responses in animals
have obtained
using genes from a variety of infectious
agents including influenza virus
hepatitis b virus human
immunodeficiency virus rabies virus
lymphocytic
choreo meningitis virus malarial
parasites and mycoplasmas
in some cases protection from disease in
animals has also been obtained
however the value and advantages of dna
vaccines must be assessed on a
case-by-case basis
and the applicability will depend on the
nature of the agent being immunized
against the nature of the antigen and
the type of immune response required for
protection
you are now introducing
foreign genetic material
into
your system
that can actually be incorporated and
become part of you
so you become
[Music]
someone else to what you really are
genetically speaking
and they are enforced using the body's
own system to now create the process to
deal
with whatever the vector is
the field of dna vaccination is
developing rapidly vaccines currently
being developed use not only dna
but also include adjuncts that assist
dna to enter cells
as i was explaining you need a vehicle
you need a transport mechanism you're
going to
override the natural defense of the body
to let any foreign dna
come into your system if it's a
retrovirus it can
reverse itself into and even spliced
into your own dna so becoming part of
you right
then you are
a gmo human you have been genetically
modified
okay
so it includes this
target
or that it may act as an adjunct in
stimulating or directing the immune
response ultimately the distinction
between a sophisticated dna vaccine and
a simple viral vector may not be clear
interesting
many aspects of the immune response
generated by dna vaccines are not
understood
we are dealing with a highly complex
system
your body is designed
to
preserve your humanity
your gene system
is designed
for absolute preservation
when you duplicate your dna
when you're actually making a
replica
in cell division
there are a number of enzymes that
ensure that the replica that you make is
spot on
because you want to be
a human in the next generation as well
it's particularly when it comes to your
germ cells right you don't want to be
a cabbage
you want to be a human
so you have all of these enzyme systems
that make sure
that the copy the carbon copy the
photocopy that you have created is an
exact replica of the original
so you have the replicase enzyme running
along your dna
replicating
the message at high speed
but you have a number
of editor enzymes running afterwards to
make sure that no mistake has been made
and you have
a number of them
about five or more
that follow the replicase enzyme and
when they see aha you've made a mistake
where adenine was supposed to be
opposite to thymine if you introduce the
wrong one there they will dismantle it
and rebuild it so that the mistake is
not noticed now what are you doing here
you're
confusing that whole system you're
actually you're actually forcing
something into the system that shouldn't
be there right
okay
so many this is a very important
sentence many aspects of the immune
response generated by dna
vaccines are not understood
you're now
using a system where you use your
human cell
to
actually
become
part of the system
to attack
an antigen
that is being introduced right
however this has not impeded significant
progress towards the use of this type of
vaccine in humans and clinical trials
have begun
now this to me is horrendous
this is horrendous
they want to introduce this vaccine in a
harsh sort of time very very quickly
within a year right
okay
and we're dealing here with the human
genetic system
and it can become part of your humanity
that means it won't only affect you it
will affect the next generation because
if
this also enters the germ cells
eventually
then you will pass it on to the next
generation you will become
a genetically modified human being
now how did god create you perfect yep
do you want someone to mess with your
genetic
makeup no
i certainly wouldn't want someone to
mess with my genetic makeup particularly
if they do not even understand what's
going to happen right correct
now what if
what if
as that previous man had said the
antigen
the antigen that triggers the immune
response
might have sequences and components that
are similar to your own cells
when your body now targets the antigen
and makes
that antibody
and binds to it
could it not also
bind to certain cells in your body that
are actually your own cells
and then you have an autoimmune response
what if it attacks your liver cells and
deactivates your liver cells there goes
your entire detox system out of the
window
they do not know exactly what it will
target
they are playing
god
now why would they do that
only people
that believe in the evolutionary process
and think that they can improve on what
god has already created as perfect
would dare to do something like this
in my opinion it is totally unethical
to introduce dna or rna sequences
which become part of my humanity
and then to test it over a period of a
year to see what it was now
if i go back
just a few years
there was
in one of my lectures i talked about the
issue of beta-carotene
as
protective against cancer
now people knew that if you consume a
lot of yellow foods then you have a
lower risk of cancer
so what is there in yellow foods
so they said okay
beta-carotene is the one that gives you
the protection against cancer
so we'll take that as an extract put it
in a tablet
sell it to you and say do you want to be
protected against cancer take regular
doses of beta-carotene the fda
which is the watch body
said excuse me you can't say that
you cannot say that this thing is going
to protect you unless you have done a
study over at least eight years eight
years yeah
eight years
so they said you can say possible but
you can't say it does that
all right so they sold it
to be the guarantee
but they also said let's do the study
so
they used people
that were inclined towards cancer
smokers
and so they took smokers and divided
them into groups and there were two big
studies done in the world on this issue
and the one group they gave
beta-carotene and the other group they
gave a placebo and then over a period of
eight years they were going to prove
that carotene gives you protection
against cancer
obviously if it works
then the group we're getting the beta
carotene will have less cancer than the
group of similar smokers that gets a
placebo right
after about
four or five years they stopped the
study
why
because those getting the beta carotene
had more cancer than those getting the
placebo which made no sense
to anyone
until science started to realize
that the complexity and the interactions
in the human body
are of such a nature
that you cannot isolate one thing and
say okay this is the cause no because
the beta-carotene is protective
when in its natural environment yes
with all the other chemicals that
interact with it isolate it and you have
a problem
so what is the healthiest
way
to fight disease
good
nutrition food also whole foods
absolutely
so now if they required
studies in excess of eight years before
you could make a claim why
are they waiving
this on this issue
on an issue where they clearly say they
do not understand it themselves
the first such vaccines licensed for
marketing are likely to use plasma dna
derived from bacterial cells in future
others may use rna or may use complexes
of nucleic acid molecules and other
entities
these guidelines address the production
and control of vaccines based on plasma
dna intended for use in humans
now
here they are introducing a totally new
way of producing vaccines
which directly
impact your genetic system
now a few years ago
monsanto modified wheat
and writers reported amid uproar of
escape gmo wheat monsanto tests more
strains
now monsanto has been taken over by
bayer
in the meantime but be that as it may
it says
while regulators probe the discovery of
an experimental genetically modified
wheat
long thought abandoned by diotec seed
development center company the company
has a new line of field experiments on
biotech wheat underway
the company is no longer pursuing the
same roundup ready spring wheat it
designed more than a decade ago to
tolerate dowsings of its roundup weed
killer
which is the strain found in a wheat
field in oregon in april
but it is developing similar strains
that are genetically altered for
herbicide tolerance as well as other
traits according to the company and
regulatory filings our work in wheat is
focused on helping improve wheat
productivity including breeding
biotechnology and improved acronomic
practices
said monsanto spokesman lee
calls in a statement
now why did we put this slide in
well this is old news
the point is there was a major uproar
about genetically modifying wheat yes
i'm asking the question
where is the same uproar in potentially
modifying human beings
shouldn't we have the same uproar
definitely
now
the ethics of changing
the gene system
is a very serious one
especially if you do not know what the
implications are
now when it comes to gmo food
again
it's one of those things where there are
many many claims
that many
food disorders and allergies
uh that have arisen amongst mankind are
as a consequence of genetically modified
food
humanity likes to play god
they like to think that they can improve
things it's like you said
the philosophy is comes from evolution
side so they think they're improving it
if you think in terms of evolutionary
scenarios
then maybe you think that you can play
god
and that you can modify it if there
isn't even more evil intent and you want
to rid the world of a large part of its
population
then that is another story
that we are dealing with
but now
this issue of immunization is not just a
question of
getting an immunity against the disease
in my opinion it has now become a moral
factor
here's an article from the business
insider from august 2020
and bill gates issued a stock warning
for the world as awful as this pandemic
is climate change could be worse
i find this interesting how they always
jump from the one to the other
so
is this preparatory
for something else
now when we think about climate change i
always think of lodatusi yes
now didn't the jesuit write that too
correct
or at least he's jesuit superiors
whoever they are well they're all
they're all together in this so they
write this article and what is ensconced
in that article sunday keeping
sunday legislation so the next step
so if you get the enforcement issue
in place using
one set of techniques
which
is linked to a health issue
but as we've seen it's probably also a
moral issue
so now they're saying okay so
the climate change is going to be worse
so then we also need that moral
directive so it's just one more step
isn't it
okay
gates is once
again urging preparedness for a
potentially devastating emergency
as awful as this pandemic is
climate change could be worse gates said
in a blog published on tuesday if you
want to understand the kind of damage
that climate change will inflict look at
covet 19
and spread the pain out over a much
longer period of time the loss of life
and economic misery caused by this
pandemic on a par with what will happen
regularly if we do not eliminate the
world's carbon emissions
this man is a genius on every level he's
a
he's an
immunization expert he is an
entrepreneur he is a
microchip expert and now he's a climate
expert as well i wonder whether he could
become a
sunday keeping expert as well
so we have some very interesting things
in the pipeline
bottom line
is it a moral issue
vaccination or is it not
so let's just listen to what our friend
tucker has to say
on the issue
so we got a new benchmark for when we
can get back to normal when we get a
vaccine
everything will be fine
once we can vaccinate against covid19
many an authority told us that they're
still telling us that the state of
virginia has announced that when a
vaccine finally does arrive it will be
mandatory
not all vaccines virginia will not
require vaccines for hepatitis or hiv
they won't require a vaccine for
meningitis either to fight despite the
fact that meningitis kills a lot more
say college students than coronavirus
does
but once we get a corona vaccine they're
telling us all will be well
but now they've changed that
not true anymore according to a new
announcement from the world health
organization a vaccine even if we get
one will not be the end of all of this
it will never end you can get your
injection they'll make you get it
but you'll still be under arrest
the world health organization says that
finding a vaccine is not the goal
reordering society is the goal
quote we will not we cannot go back to
the way things were that's a direct
quote from the leader of the world's
health organization dr tedros who by the
way is not really a doctor
because covet 19 is not a public health
crisis really or even a mere virus
according to ted rose covid19 is in fact
this may surprise you coveted 19 is
really
about global warming
as he puts it quote the covet 19
pandemic has given new impetus to the
need to accelerate efforts to respond to
climate change
i bet you didn't see that coming bill
gates did he agrees that wholeheartedly
earlier this month gates posted an essay
to his personal website which you
probably haven't seen arguing that the
lesson of the corona pandemic
is that the rest of us will have to
sacrifice even more to save the earth
from warming
now for people who are not billionaire
global influencers this is all pretty
confusing
quick what does the coronavirus have to
do with climate change well for one
thing china caused both of them that's
the obvious link
but that is definitely not the point dr
tedros and bill gates are making both of
them bow before china they would never
meaningfully criticize the chinese
government so you can be assured that's
not the connection they're drawing no
for dr tedros and bill gates pandemic
and climate change share a very
different connection both are useful
pretexts for mass social control
both are essentially unsolvable crises
they can harness to bypass democracy and
force powerless populations to obey
their commands
how would a rational person assess
global warming
if you really believe that carbon
emissions were distorting the earth's
climate and that's the claim they make
maybe they're right
then you would take a very close look at
the forces behind those carbon emissions
you would ask hard questions about the
global economy you'd wonder who's
profiting from this system that's
destroying the earth
how exactly do the riches most powerful
people in the world that would be big
finance and the tech monopolies
contribute to carbon emissions that
would be the first question you would
ask that's the logical way to think
about climate change
and if you begin to think that way you
might wind up concluding that people
like i don't know michael bloomberg were
in fact climate criminals their private
jets alone produce more carbon emissions
a year than entire african villages do
not to mention more than your
neighborhood does a lot more
but tellingly no one on the
environmental left ever criticizes
michael bloomberg he's considered a
leader in the fight against climate
change
here's another data point for you that
you won't see on television less than a
month ago on july 31st the cdc centers
for disease control in atlanta our
primary public health organization
funded by the federal government
released guidelines to state health
departments about patients infected with
the chronovirus how do you track the
spread of this disease
in a footnote in the release the cdc
acknowledged that researchers lack
evidence that quote
masks offer any protection against
coronavirus any at all
as health officials work to track the
spread of the virus the cdc suggested
that they ignore
whether or not people were wearing masks
in other words wearing a mask may be
completely irrelevant to the spread of
the virus
huh
so there is still no proof that masks
protect us against covid19
that is apparently the conclusion the
cdc reached it's not something trump
tweeted the cdc put that in a release to
the states it seems like a blockbuster
story
why isn't that on page one of the new
york times
why is the entire media the entire
leadership class of the united states of
america ignoring this mass are
obligatory they're mandatory everywhere
just the other day joe biden announced
that if he's elected you'll be required
to wear a mask when you're alone outside
what is going on
you know what's going on
fear works
the more afraid you are the more you
will accept again a feature of human
nature the more cut off you are from
your family and your friends the more
power they have to control you
so bottom line
stepping stone or not
i think so i think it's a stepping stone
to the next act in the great saga
and whether people want to believe it or
not
the religious system
is at the heart of the matter yes
and we have a war
between god
and his arch enemy
and their respective representatives
after all the head of the jesuits is
called a general
which means he is part of an army
perhaps you can put a link in
to crete to malta to see how
this works
let's have a look at what the official
catholic newspaper has to say on this
issue
this is slos of ataro romano this comes
from july 2020 the project for a new
world
once we know where to go
going there becomes easier
muhammad yanus economist 2006 nobel
prize
laureate and the creator of modern micro
credit has rather clear ideas about what
to do in a world potentially changed by
the coronavirus
to begin with to protect everyone the
entire world from the virus with a
vaccine that will be declared a global
common good
who's the champion of common good the
jesuit the jesuits
then simply to create a very different
world
i'm so happy to see that pope francis
has the same feeling as i do
going back to the old world would be an
insane action because the world that
we're coming from was very inhospitable
world
the most prosperous nations in the world
were the protestant nations
they had to be brought
down and that world
of prosperity and freedom had to be
destroyed
and your freedom had to be taken away
because they want to have the same
control
as they had in the middle ages
interesting
so that world he says was very
inhospitable well it was very hospitable
until they started interfering and
fomenting
all the riots and the chaos because
after all
ordo abcao
is what they stand for
a terrifying world
a world which was about to finish itself
by global warming they always have to
bring that in that's their
trump card
by wealth concentration
excuse me what has global warming got to
do with that by artificial intelligence
removing human beings from jobs
at that point everything was converging
and we had only a few years left before
the whole world collapsed
from the global warming side there is a
very small time left
before the world becomes unlivable i
think the devil knows that his time is
up
and therefore he has to push his agenda
and who are those that irritate him
the commandment keeping people of god
those who keep the commandments of god
and hold to the testimony of jesus in
other words they believe what jesus
believed they believe the word of god
which they obviously don't
it is the same for wealth concentration
which is ticking time bomb which can
explode politically socially with anger
and the same for artificial intelligence
because of which people will have no job
or no work for them
that's not the kind of world that we
would like to go back to that's the
point and coronavirus has done a great
favor despite the fact
that it made a horrible situation of the
planet but it has done a great favor to
us because it stopped the machine in
rushing towards death
fascinating
so let's not go into plandemic or
pandemic but the issues are
very clear indeed
as a closing statement 1 corinthians 3
16 to 17 says
know ye not that you are the temple of
god
and that the spirit of god dwelleth in
you
if any man defile the temple of god him
shall god destroy
for the temple of god is holy which
temple
ye are
so has it become a moral issue
i believe it has
especially if it can
modify you genetically
yes that's not what god wants
i don't think that's what god wants and
i think god
will very soon intervene
and then we will see destruction on a
scale
unimaginable
now in our next
episodes we will move from the stepping
stone issue
to the real issue which is the final
issue the issue of worship
and then we will discuss
the events up until the coming of christ
after the coming of christ and the
restoration of all things
we have to make decisions
and
a number of small decisions eventually
lead to
large decisions
may god help us to be faithful
and to make a choice which is in harmony
with his will shall we pray thank you
our loving heavenly father
when humanity believes that it can play
god
then a point has been reached where the
god of the universe the creator of all
things that made things good very good
will have no choice but to intervene
i believe it was like that in the ante
deluvian world lord and i believe we are
approaching that same point
and what is left for us to do is to make
decisions
decisions based on
a moral directive
which we find in the word of god
help us to make right decisions
so that we stand
on the right side of the issue in jesus
name amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications
to watch the next video
click here thank you